uh the reason i want to show it to you
is because it's a pretty classic example
of how they give you a situation with
very little information
and just like in exponential growth and
again you have to draw some conclusions
about the equations you're going to have
and um use those equations to
provide whatever information they're
asking for so
here you go look up there's a spring or
some kind of elastic
thing you'll get very sick of this kind
of example you think can't message us
think of more examples
and the answer is yeah they probably
could but
it does just find the maths works so
you might like to draw this and he wants
to have a picture
um you've got a spring and it's moving
up and down it's like a weight at the
bottom okay
so like think of a think of a slinky i
suppose okay
now here's all they tell you for the
setup okay there's very very little
information
it takes four seconds to go from
the bottom of the motion and they tell
you you know it the closest it gets to
the floor is 15 centimeters
from the floor it takes four seconds to
go from there
to the top of the motion which is 55
centimeters from the floor
i just realized this is a really really
short room but anyway not to scale okay
you have the idea four seconds to go
from here to here and i assume because
we're we're modelling on simple
harmonization
motion four seconds to come back down
again okay
those are the uh the measurements they
the last they tell you that it starts t
equals zero
starts at the center of motion moving
upward okay
full stop that's it that's all you need
to know
to develop all of your equations of
motion okay
so let's think about this what's the key
data here um
it starts at the center of motion okay
so that automatically tells you
right away which are we likely to choose
from our sort of
four to choose from um displacement
equations
which are you likely to choose probably
sine
right because sine starts at the center
of motion okay
it's moving upward so are we going to
choose positive sign or negative sign
positive it goes up okay good so right
away i have this
x is equal to a sine
nt this is what i already know but i
haven't accounted for all of the
information in the question yet
okay so for instance um you might want
to know something like
n which has to do with
frequency or period right where do i get
that from i get that from this
four seconds to go from the
bottom sorry bottom to the top okay
now just be careful just be careful what
would that look like
um just as an example not thinking about
the um
the constant up and down yet if i'm at
the start of
here at the origin right and i go
upwards and then i come downwards and
then i go up and so on
okay where is that four seconds four
seconds to go from the bottom of motion
to the top well it happens lots of times
but one example
would be in here right the bottom of
motion
to the top of motion okay so that
interval on the time axis
that's four seconds
four seconds so therefore be careful
what is the period of motion
it's eight seconds it's not for classic
beginner's error okay
you see four seconds since so you love
sorry you jump right in
jump uh into two pi on n right equals
four but it's not equal to four
that's not the full cycle of motion
right you've actually got to go
all the way okay so if i want to work
out m
i would say p
equals two pi on m okay but i know what
the period is it's eight seconds
yep so i can switch these around kind of
what value do i get for m
2.8 which is part four right
good so that's good i can actually pop
that in there
okay now i've got i've got my horizontal
sort of scale taken care of right
but i haven't done anything about the
vertical i don't know how far this goes
up and down and i don't know
if how far i've been shifted up and down
okay so you've got this information here
15
55. great 15 55. what do you think is
the easiest piece of information to gain
from that
with the least calculation looking for a
couple of different numbers here
what can you see
what am i looking for what am i looking
for well something like say
the amplitude would be useful right the
amplitude looks to me like
it's from the top to the bottom it's
half of that isn't it right because we
would say
the amplitude of sine is is one it's not
two
right so you take this distance which is
40
and you take
half of that and that would give you
your amplitude wouldn't it okay so my
amplitude here
my a is 20
okay that's good but i still haven't
accounted for everything
this equation as it stands well it goes
through the floor at the moment
okay so what can i do to change this
so that it accounts for these kinds of
numbers any suggestions
what did we look at at the start of a
lesson
what kinds of ways can we modify this
equation
i could add a constant couldn't i i have
to move it upwards how far
upwards would i have to move it
it'd be it'd be halfway between the
bottom at the top
halfway right that reads to be something
like
35 right because then you go 20 down to
15 and 20 up to 55.
so here's one alternative okay
so what have i got here this is my
equation of displacement okay
now eventually at this point we don't
have to write this as our equation of
displacement
i've kind of made an assumption here
right what is x 0 in this context
x equals zero what's what does x equal
zero represent
it represents a place on this diagram
what place
it represents the ground the floor right
so i actually am saying let x
equals zero be the floor
but i don't have to i can make x equal
zero wherever i
like i could if i wanted to i could make
x equals 0 be the center of motion which
is 35 centimeters above the ground
okay and then i wouldn't have to worry
about this constant i just have to
account for it later on if i wanted to
work out things like say
where am i okay all right so being that
you do have that choice
for now this is what we've gone with
okay how am i going to answer part a
it's not that hard we've done all of the
hard work actually the hard work was
making
this guy now if you want to know where
you are after three seconds
right because we've formed the right
equation all you have to do is let's
take t equals three and let's do it
when time equals three
right i'm going to get x equals 20 sine
3 pi on 4. what's 3 pi
4 sine 3.4
that should be let's see from naught to
pi for sine and positive right
and it should be the same as pi on four
and three pi four should be the same
right that's one on root two
plus thirty-five i could divide through
that that would be
ten root two
here i am centimeters above
the floor okay so if i had for instance
if i had not chosen this equation not
let x equal zero be the four
i could have said this
then when i evaluated t equals three
down to
here i would get this
right so then what would you do if that
was the um if that was your x equals
zero that you chose
you'd have to say this represents a
distance not above the floor
but above the center of mission and
you'd say the center of motions at 35
and you would come up with the same
answer
because you'd add that number okay so
that's what you do if you chose that
how fast is it going at that center of
motion
and because i'm interested only in speed
i don't care which way
right and it's going to be the same
either way just positive negative how do
i work out the speed
i need the move don't i sorry
by the way if you do choose to go for x
dot and x double dot
notation which is fine and the questions
will as well
can i recommend that you make your dots
obscenely large
um because you know when you're in a
hurry and you write this or you write
that
um they look really really similar
particularly when you're in the exam so
if you're going to use dots
then make them huge and unmistakable
okay
excellent uh here's my equation right so
when i differentiate
pi and four is going to come out the
front so what would be my derivative
bye bye cause
and of course our constant 35 just drops
off no problem
so i want to know the center of motion
there's lots of times when
i'm at the center of motion right what
might be a good thing to choose
how about time zero that's a nice
convenient thing to put in
right so if i put in sorry when
t equals zero like you pick whatever
value is convenient obviously i'm going
to be at the um
i'm gonna be at the center of motion in
another four seconds but why would you
put in t equals four when you can put in
t equals zero
right um especially when you see you'll
just get
cos zero which is one
so you just get five pi right so this is
a velocity right so it should be in
meters
per second because i've got sorry
centimeters per second because i've got
centimeters here and i've got seconds
here so far so good last part
i want to work out the maximum
acceleration maximum acceleration
now where does the maximum acceleration
occur
at the extremities good we're starting
to get the rubber band in our head right
so i can choose um 15 or i can choose
55. either of those will do fine right
obviously
it will be going in a different
direction but i'm still going to get the
um the value
right so you have a couple of choices
what could you do i want to find that
acceleration that would be the natural
thing to do
differentiate again right because that's
how we got velocity yeah
you'd say x double dot and then you
differentiate this and get something out
except we're in simple harmonic motion i
already know what the second derivative
is i know what acceleration is because i
know what displacement is
right right so so this is equal to
now careful because we changed the
center of motion at least in this
equation we did
right this is not going to be n squared
x sorry minus n squared x
what's it going to be it'll be x
minus 35 right now a couple of things
don't forget
it's actually not n i know what n is
right so i'm just going to stick that in
right that's n squared isn't it and so
we said look just pick an extremity pick
15 or pick 55
i'm going to pick 15 because that
negative and that negative will cancel
give me a positive
is that okay so coming over here
when x equals 15. okay
you go x double dot equals
and i've got 15 minus 35 in there
that's negative 20 the negatives cancel
so you're getting 20
pi squared on 16. that's
5 pi squared on 4.
yeah now it's acceleration right so it
should be sorry it's a terrible 4.
centimeters per second
squared or second to the power of minus
two if you prefer
okay by the way you know
what would we have done if we didn't do
it this way what we've done we would
have to differentiate right
ah but then if you differentiate your in
terms of time
so then you have to work out now where
am i at one of those extremities you
need a t
value to put into that because it's a
function of time right so then you work
that out introducing more places where
error comes in
and then you substitute you should get
to the same value right
but can you see being that we already
know this and we know how simple
harmonic motion
behaves take advantage of that go
straight to the
differential equation because you can
use it that's the point